Vous aimez la nostalgie hein vous l'appréciez
J'ai vu l'émotion sur vos visages quand vous m'avez vu enfant, à 8 ans, avec ma mèche rebelle et ma tête à claques
Il se trouve que j'aime moi aussi la nostalgie et aujourd'hui, on a plus 8 ans, mais on va jouer aux jeux auxquels je jouais quand j'avais 8 ans
À savoir des jeux flash, à l'époque je jouais sur Absoluflash et le site n'existe plus
Et pas de panique, les jeux flash, ça existe toujours, on va jouer à une petite flopée de ces derniers
Et cela va nous divertir
(Générique)
Ha bah pourquoi ne pas tout de suite aller dans les meilleurs jeux de la semaine ?
Fidget Spinner, Naaan..
Nan ne me dites pas, naan, non c'est non
C'est un non ! C'est un gros non !
Énervé ? Détruisez cette bannière ! Oui je le fais !
J'le fais ça m'a vénère ton putain d'hand spinner !
J'la pète, y'a quoi derrière ? Me dis pas qu'y a un hand spinner derrière
(Musique de Zelda)
Haaa putain de merde !
(Générique)
La reine haaaaa!
C'est quoi ça ?
Mais vous allez briser des enfances la mon gars !
La reine des glaces chez le dermatologue
(Rires)
Mais qu'est ce qu'il se passe sur ce site ?
En plus c'est la reine des glaces mec, si elle a des verrues, elle peut se les brûler elle même avec le froid
L'azote elle le crée la reine des glaces ok ?
Bon... "heiiiin"
* L'incompréhension*
On va t'aider, on va t'aider voilà on retire tes petits boutons, un par un, ça va aller, ça va aller, t'inquiètes pas, t'inquiète pas
Anna ne te considère plus comme sa soeur c'est tout ! Sinon ça va !
Des ciseaux , haaa y'a des poils en plus , d'accord c'est pas qu'un problème de bouton là c'est pas que de la peau
Là on a de la barbe, on a de la bebar
Et là je fais quoi avec ça ?
Ho nan...
On lui laserise la peau mais ça va pas putain ça m'écœure
Mais c'est le traitement d'un vrai problème de peau ça mec de te mettre un sable laser sur la gueule ?
Ha bah vu ce qu'il a pris Dark Vador il devait avoir beaucoup d'acné pfff
J'trouve qu'elle était pas mal, parce que t'as vu y'avait un petit sous-entendu et tout mais naan, naan mais arrêtez
Haaan et en plus elle a des bactéries ?
Mec j'espère vraiment qu'à la fin elle sera belle
J'veux plus jamais voir Elsa dans cet état
Ça m'a brisé le cœur
Ok  niveau suivant
Ha de l'électricité maintenant
(Rires) mais meeec
C'est n'importe quoi !!
Bientôt faudra lui mettre des coups de pied pour retirer son acné quoi
Bah oui ! Bah oui un pistolet laser mec
ça retire de ouf
J'crois que j'prend ce jeu trop à cœur
J'oublie que c'est un jeu destiné aux enfants de 6 ans
Ça va pas du tout
Ok...
Ha y'a des araignées !
Ho putain c'est fini
Me regarde pas comme ça je n'ai rien fait
C'est de la torture quoi , en faite c'est du clickbait pour enfant
Quand l'enfant il voit la reine des neiges avec une peau ignoble et tout avec marqué : aide la, aide la ! Il fait : haaa maman !!
Et il clique pour l'aider parce qu'il y croit l'enfant putain
C'est scandaleux
(Générique)
Ahh les opération j'aime bien ça, ça c'est drôle ça
Êtes-vous prêt à avoir envie de vous flinguer ?
C'est parti
Chuuuuut
Vous entrez dans le bloc
Désinfectez-vous les mains on va opérer
C'est parti
N'essaye pas de reproduire ça chez toi
(Rires)
C'est génial !
Vous pensez qu'étant enfant on aurait pu se dire : hé Stephanie, viens j'vais essayer sur toi. j'parlais comme ça quand j'étais enfant
*Lit le texte*
Héé c'est ma grand mère qui a eu ça
C'est exactement ce que ma grand mère a eu
Anesthésie locale, ah c'est avec des gouttes les anesthésies locales pour les yeux ?
Oh c'est cool, ça change de l'énorme aiguille de 8 cm qu'on t'enfonce dans la peau
Ok on nettoie, voilà
Oh putain
ça me donne la gerbe ce zoom , ça me donne la gerbe (Rires)
J'ai l'impression que d'un coup on va découvrir un truc bizarre
(Musique de Zelda)
*Lit le texte*
Mais met le dès le début putain !
Uuuh, rien que ça, ça me fait serrer les fesses
On commence par une petite incision dans la cornée
C'est parti
Ah mec ça me met dans des états cette merde alors que c'est des dessins
J'crois on l'a déjà fait un jour en vidéo cette opération en tout cas c'est dégueulasse
C'est ignoble
On l'a déjà fait, je m'en souviens, attends, suis-je en train de.. On arrête tout, on arrête tout
Là on s'en bat les couilles de la patiente qui se fait opérer on s'en fout
On a déjà fait cette opération vous vous rendez compte ?
J'avait oublié, c'est peut-être mon cerveau qu'il faut opérer là
Hop là ça dégage !
(Générique)
MooMoo.io , c'est quoi ça?
Y'a tellement eu une grosse flopée de jeux .io après agar.io et tout là
Qu'est ce que je dois faire ? C'est quoi ce jeu ? J'dois miner ? Mais nan mais t'es sérieux là ? Ma vie c'est ça
Bon bah ok
C'est sûr quand j'aurais terminé de miner, on va avoir un pouvoir de ouf après, regardez bien, regardez bien !
Dafuck ! J'me suis cassé les couilles pour rien ?!
Oui t'es mort
Tiens !!!
Mais putain...Je clique sur la fenêtre pourquoi ça scrol la page !!
(Générique)
Mais nan ! Le rêve, Drift Runner 3D mec !
Il est sorti ? Ça fait 2 ans et demi que j'attends que ce jeu sorte mec attends
Ne me dis pas qu'on va pouvoir drifter avec des voitures en 3D s'il te plaît
Hooooooo!!
Mon dieu !!!
C'est énorme !!!
J'en ai marre...
Quand tu passes une vitesse, ça fait le bruit des portes d'un bus qui s'ouvrent c'est génial
(Générique)
Le premier rendez-vous d'Ellie
Oh putain il est bg
Faut absolument qu'on réussisse à le séduire
Comment on va s'y prendre
Salut Ellie , j't'ai repéré à l'école, ça te dirait qu'on sorte ensemble aujourd'hui ?
Oh ! Celui sur qui j'ai des vues me propose de sortir avec lui aujourd'hui
J'ai la voix abîmée j'arrive pas à faire la femme
Aide moi à me préparer pour notre premier rendez-vous
Ohlala putain mec on dirait la Hahaaa !
Quelle tenue on va mettre pour Ellie
Oh la coupe cheveux courts allez hop
La coupe reine
Un petit jean avec des trous ou un petit short, il fait chaud c'est l'été
Le haut avec le pug bien évidemment
Et la petite veste rose comme ça c'est très bien
Le petit sac bob l'éponge et le bandana c'est parti
Et l'appareil photo pour mener à bien notre vlog
Bien sûr
Nous passons maintenant au maquillage
Ce qui est bien, c'est que c'est pas cliché du tout j'adore
Un poil de masse quoi ?
Ah c'est à moi de maquiller avec la souris d'accord
Et voilà ça suffira juste du mascara
La beauté naturelle
Le touchera en plein coeur
Tain vas y j'm'en fou j'veux savoir comment ça va se passer leur rendez-vous
Et le moment qu'on attend tous le rendez-vous
Comment ça va se passer
Il nous a amené des fleurs
Attends c'est tout ? C'est juste une image ?
*tapote la souris* Nan nan
Nan nan nan nan Ellie nan !
Mais nan mais j'm'en bats les couilles de la télécharger, mais nan
Mais nan !!
Quelle arnaque ça dégage
Oh putain c'est quoi ce truc qui s'est ouvert
Ooh on dirait un cauchemar, c'est que des trucs où faut habiller des filles, les maquiller et leurs mettre du vernis mec
ça dégage alors !
(Générique)
Ooh un jeu de chasse
Deer Hunter
Ne me dit pas qu'on va pouvoir chasser des cerfs et des biches
Ne me dis pas ça
Haaan
(Musique de fin de niveau)
Collatéral Head Shot !
C'est qui le meilleur au sniper !!
(Générique)
Oh un test d'amour mec
Oh oui, j'entre mon nom Lucas, j'entre son nom Maxenss
(Chanson d'amour)
*battement de coeur*
*battement de coeur* + (Musique romantique)
Oooooh !
On est compatible à 85% mon amour !
Oh même la caméra est jalouse elle même elle s'est arrêtée..
(Générique)
Oh ! Attendez ! Y'a Ellie qui est de retour et qui veut qu'on se prépare ensemble
Get ready with me
Oh tu vas nous faire un what in my phone tag
Hé ! mais attends ! J'crois que si j'prends des morceaux de vidéos de vraies youtubeuses beauté, et que je les mets par dessus le gameplay, on va croire qu'Ellie nous fait une vidéo la !
(Générique)
Je commence par appliquer ma petite crème pour le visage
Sur tout mon visage
Heu voila comme ça c'est fait et ça laisse le temps à ma peau de bien faire pénétrer ma crème pendant que je ferais autre chose
On passe aux sourcils !
On applique la poudre
J'utilise ensuite le mascara et vous allez voir
Le rendu qu'il donne sur mes cils c'est assez dingue
Bon voila c'était une journée un petit peu comme les autres on va dire
On s'abonne ! C'est la nouvelle youtubeuse qui fait le buzz sur internet c'est Ellie, un maximum d'abonnement pour Ellie !
Et bien voila les amis c'est déjà la fin de cette vidéo sur ces différents jeux flash j'espère que ça vous a plu ! Si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à l'aimer comme d'habitude
Et bah écoutez les jeux flash ça a bien changé
J'suis impressionné par le nombre de jeux où faut juste habiller ou maquiller une fille. C'est incroyable
Bref c'est le moment d'arrêter d'être nostalgique et de se dire au revoir
à bientôt !